a more mysterious thing to go down when
stranger things three premieres on July
4th but before that Millie Bobby Brown
is terrorizing the set of Godzilla and
our Brooke Anderson caught up with her
exclusively in Atlanta I pranked
everybody on set
everybody gets pranked we put
cockroaches in the milk cartons
we put snakes in the water coolers they
got me back with getting little plastic
balls and putting it they they got a net
for my door and then started stuffing to
him
Eadie's try and prank me so then I
grabbed all the balls and put them in
Michaels trailer Millie's pranking
partner in crime
director Michael Dougherty Michael
bought an exorcist doll and I hid it in
our Vera's trailer so so when she opened
the door it would fall on her today
Linda Blair jumped out on my trailer
there's always stuff coming at me from
my fridge but it's not just fun and
games on the set of Godzilla king of the
monsters where we will see Godzilla's
return to take on other famous monsters
this is Millie's first film role since
stranger things skyrocketed her to thing
it's definitely hard it's a lot of
stunts but I love it it's it's the
challengers is has been accepted I don't
wanna interrupt Kyle Chandler plays the
15 year-olds on-screen death and
couldn't help but crash our interview a
really great workout oh he's like an
uncle yeah he's amazing who or what do
you credit with keeping you grounded my
brother you know he like he'll always
say like the quote in the house is like
you're not celebrity in this house
coming on set I'm like people are like
Millie and I'm like oh no you come home
and my brothers have got me in a
headlock
[Music]